this summer I had hoped to find a way to
prepare not just for another year
but another term because that is what
this year requires
I have not been able to do that
and so today I'm announcing that I will
not be seeking re-election
and then my turn as prime minister will
conclude no later than the 7th of
February
this has been the most fulfilling five
and a half years of my life
but has also had its challenges
I know what this job takes and I know
that I no longer have enough in the tank
to do it justice
it's that simple
I know there will be much discussion in
the aftermath of this decision as to
what the so-called real reason was
I can tell you that what I'm sharing
today is it
the only interesting angle that you will
find
is that after going on six years of some
big challenges I am human
politicians are human
we give all that we can for as long as
we can
and then it's time
and for me it's time
I think the cumulative uh challenges
that we've faced as a team and they have
been extraordinary
has taken its toll I consider this job a
privilege but I am also human and so my
reflection has been an entirely personal
one and I will add that I had the
support of my family to continue